today we welcome to the program lee
drutman who's the author of
the book breaking the two-party doom
loop the case for
multi-party democracy in america also
co-host of the podcast politics in
question and a senior fellow
in the political reform program at new
america and by the way
he i was hoping to surprise him with
this but he was told
guest number 1000 on the david pakman
show
unique guest now some guests have
appeared many times but we're saying
not interview 1000 lead but guest 1000
which i feel like is a more precise
metric
uh yes and and it's important to have
precision in your metrics
or else or else you mismeasure and you
lead to erroneous conclusions
right and and and so i guess maybe we'll
apply that to
our first topic which is um in assessing
the the two-party uh doom loop that we
have as you call it
do you have a sense of how to measure
whether the republican and democratic
party right now on policy
are closer or further apart than they've
been historically
well i i think they are not
super close together but i mean actually
this is something that
scholars of democracy around the world
do try to measure
and you know compared to a lot of other
countries
uh which just have a broader spectrum of
of parties because they have multiple
parties the
democratic party and the republican
party are
not super far apart on policy uh
you know it's there's actually probably
more in common in a lot of policy areas
what
they are divided on is geography
and identity and culture and you know
there's a real sense that you know
democrats and republicans feel like the
other party represents a very
different and and each of them extreme
version
of what america ought to be and the so
the real divide
is more about social polarization
than i think it is about policy
polarization
over the last couple of years we've seen
on the one hand this idea that trumpism
is something different from what the
republican party has been
for the last decade or 15 years or so or
maybe in the post-reagan era we could
even say of the last 30 years
and yet at the same time we have
actually seen
republicans by and large get behind
donald trump with rare exceptions so
can what's your sense of whether the
republican party is
fractured at this time well
i mean american parties are always
fractured because there are
these big tent parties in a sense
they're trying to represent
half of the country i mean so yeah there
i think are are
a few different visions of what the
republican party ought to be within the
republican party
and you know donald trump is
sort of the vessel for at least two of
those visions
uh and organizes the republican party
not around a positive vision of what
republicans ought to stand for but
as a combative force
fighting the democrats trolling the libs
i mean that that's the
the uh motivating force of
the republican party right now is
preventing democrats from
being in power uh it's you know very
much
a sense of negative partisanship and
when you ask a lot of republicans what
what they like about donald trump they
like that he's a fighter
right i mean it's not that they like his
particular policies they like that he's
fighting for them
uh and i think that that is the way that
he holds a party together that i think
if they actually had to have a
disagreement
or had to have a a debate on policy
you'd actually
find much more uh diversity
in the party it's before we move on to
how we might break this two-party system
that we have
it see it seems to me as someone who's
on the left
that a fractured republican party is is
good for the left and when i look at
what's happening in georgia
if you have some republicans who are
saying we've got to vote and then others
who are saying hey the whole thing is
rigged maybe just boycott it and stay
home and trump's going after the
the governor and secretary of state of
georgia that type of chaos seems like it
would be good for the left
what's your sense of that i mean it's
good
i'm not sure if it's good for i mean
maybe maybe not i mean i think one of
the
challenges uh is that what
you know unless there's like a real
genuine split in the party
in which you know the the party actually
breaks apart
now a lot of folks are you know going to
decide well
you know i don't love i think i think
this has been kind of a
a through line you know there's a lot of
folks on the right say well you know
trump is kind of
boorish and i don't like his tweeting
and maybe he shouldn't done this
but i can't vote for the democrats so i
guess i have to vote for the republicans
and
you know hope that eventually this this
does
dies out uh you know i i mean i think it
i mean i don't think so much as what's
you know i i mean i i consider myself on
the left
um but i i think more about what's good
for the country and what's good for the
continuation
of our democracy and you know i think
that
having a fractured and chaotic party
that can only be
unified by an authoritarian
uh you know cult of personality cult
leader which i guess is
probably the best description of donald
trump is very dangerous that you need a
center right
or a right party that believes in
basic idea that you have free and fair
elections and those
elections are legitimate and you know we
we don't have that
right now and that is that is the true
danger so i mean
maybe there'll be some fracture and
there'll be a a
a faction of the party that says look
you know
whatever disagreements we have with the
left we
agree that we have to have a democracy
with free and fair elections
and that is the cornerstone of our
system
and you know we can argue about tax
policy later but the first thing we have
to agree on is
that you know you have elections that
are legitimate
so what would have to change for the u.s
to go
more in the direction of of having at
least one more party that's regularly
viable a few of the things i've talked
to my audience about
include changing how politics is
financed
would probably be near the top of the
list uh also
potentially changing first past the post
voting at least
within states so that the spoiler effect
which keeps a lot of people
uh from going in the direction of an
alternative to democrats and republicans
would probably be near the top of the
list
do you agree with these two items what
other items would would you add
yeah i mean i i certainly support
campaign finance reform but i think the
the real reason why we have just two
parties is because we have a voting
system first past the
post plurality single winner elections
in which votes
for third parties new parties minor
parties
are effectively wasted and so all the
all the energy and focus goes into the
top two parties and it's very hard for
new parties to emerge now the us is an
outlier in this respect i mean
most of the world's democracies
uh have proportional voting systems that
do not
punish smaller parties most
democracies around the world are
proportional multi-party democracies and
there are certainly a range
of of rules that you know
can structure the party competition i
think a healthy number of parties is
probably between
four and six i'm not suggesting that we
become israel and have like you know 13
parties uh you know and israel uses a
very extreme form of proportional
representation that i
that that neither i nor most people who
study electoral systems would recommend
you know i think the the model here
should be something more like ireland
which uses multi-member
uh districts you typically three to five
member districts with
um uh a ranked choice voting uh
so they just call it proportional
representation i think another model
this
might work better for the senator that
would require constitutional amendment
is what new zealand does you know which
is they people elect
uh representatives for for their
legislative district
and then they have a second party list
vote in which they vote for a party
and the parties get effectively
compensatory seats in the legislature
based on how well they do on the party
list so that
it ensures that if you know 53 percent
of people want democrats
democrats have 53 percent of the seats
not just how how
democrats and republicans happen to
shake out in particular states or
districts
how do you build consensus to even
change that system right because i mean
even the conversation about
electoral vote versus popular vote to
pick the president one party has
benefited from the fact that we have an
electoral college
and one party has lost out on on
multiple
uh uh presidents in the white house as a
result of that so
there's a large portion of those in
power who
have no incentive to change that system
how do you how do we get over that hump
uh there are some people in power who
want to
maintain the status quo but i i would
say a few things
um you know one if you talk to most
people in power
uh elected democrats elected republicans
you know
a lot of them feel like things are
really broken
and they feel stuck in this system and
they feel trapped in this system
and they you know don't actually want
you know in their preferred world they
they wouldn't just be foot soldiers
in an endless partisan trench warfare
where they keep digging
deeper and deeper holes now you know
i think within the democratic party and
within the republican party as we were
discussing
you know there are different factions
there are different groups that feel
like they have a
vision uh for how politics ought to be
and that vision is uh
is is suppressed in this current binary
hyper partisan
system in which nothing actually happens
because the parties are kind of
deadlocked
so i mean i think there are enough
people in
elected office maybe not the heads of
their parties but who might say look
this system isn't working for us and you
know
maybe we can try uh a different
system in which maybe we'd get to play a
different role perhaps a better role
in actually working out uh legislative
compromise
and you know trying to trying to solve
problems instead of just
fighting each other in endless messaging
wars in which all this money
is wasted uh just to to fight to
basically the same point that we've
always been i mean for all the money
that has been spent on this election
it's remarkable
how little movement there was among
voters i mean it was you know
basically the same same outcome as as
2016
and the popular vote with biden winning
a little more and biden did a little bit
better in a handful of
states in that you know yes
that very very very well said so we've
talked a little bit about the republican
party we've talked about
uh multi-party uh possibilities
to talk a little bit as we get down to
the end of our time
about the democratic party um there was
a modest amount of sort of never biden
sentiment
during the primaries and even shortly
after joe biden it became clear joe
biden would be the democratic nominee
but in the end
most democratic voters did vote for joe
biden even if they
would have preferred someone more
progressive um
is the democratic party likely or how
likely is it to fracture
in a in a significant way between the
sort of
bulk of the party and the progressive
wing
well yeah i mean i think that the fights
will continue i mean
i mean a fracture would be significant
and i think
democrats unified around biden because
they wanted trump out of office yes that
it was
you know i mean if you looked at polls
it was not a uh
a resounding you know vote of enthusiasm
for joe biden as much as it was a
resounding vote of
of get donald trump out of office and
and
now you know uh you know
who knows i mean i think you know i
think i think the
the progressive left feels um
you know like it it doesn't have a lot
of room to maneuver given the narrow
majorities that democrats have in the
house
um on the other hand gives them more
leverage but
you know the threat of trump winning in
2024
or somebody trump-like winning in 2024 i
mean
this is this is the problem with our
you know closely fought binary politics
is that
everybody is just trying to win the next
election
and so there's all this you know well
you know we're not going to discuss
ideas we're not going to have debates
about policy you know we just have to
make the republicans look bad we just
have to keep them out of office and then
we have the luxury
of having an actual discussion over
policy because we can't
fracture and that's just the kind of
stasis
that politics is it i mean in order i
mean politics has to be
dynamic there have to be fights and
there have to be disagreements and there
has to be uncertainty and there have to
be
uh you know opportunities to form new
and different coalitions
but we're we're in this kind of frozen
state in which everybody feels like
they're losing
everybody feels like you know just one
election and the entire
uh character of america will be
destroyed and
it creates this incredible sense
of frustration meanwhile there are real
problems that we have to deal with
um climate i think being to me
the the most important and existential
uh
you know that we're just ignoring
yeah i i am less concerned as you're
pointing out
the the fact that there would be
disagreement within
or or between parties but even within
we're kind of talking about here
i'm less concerned by that and that's
less of a sign that
that that of a problem in the democratic
party for me the concern comes
if there is a wing that is representing
a significant number of americans that
seems to
never actually get anything for the
those constituents
that are that are in line with them that
is more of a concern for me than the
fact that there are disagreements
or even factions because that actually
seems completely natural natural and
healthy the way you're pointing out
yeah it is natural and healthy and you
know if we were in a multi-party
system you know there would be a social
democratic party
and there would be a you know moderate
centrist democrat party
and then those parties could go directly
to the voters rather than having to
compete in
in different primaries and you know we
we'd know
uh what the popularity of their
different programs
were and then those would be bargaining
chips as they worked out
uh legislative solutions uh instead
there's a sense that you know democrats
have to hold together they have to win
that majority which
means they have to win those you know
slightly conservative suburban districts
which means they can't do anything too
progressive uh
and that's just the way the math works
yeah no question about it
uh we've been speaking with lee drupman
who's author of breaking the two-party
doom loop the case for multi-party
democracy in american
in america he also co-hosts the podcast
politics in question and is a senior
fellow in the political
reform program at new america ali i
really appreciate your time today
thank you david this was a this was a
great conversation and you know i hope
folks
uh you know think about this as a
serious solution to our gridlocked and
broken politics